plein temps notre à la fin
on est jour 26 de la campagne électorale
ou l'art de chanter la vie petite
déambulation matinale au programme
cinq minutes plus tard la marchande
tente de faire cadeau des cafés
et c'est parti pour la marche philippe
couillard est inspiré par le mobilier
urbain
les amoureux qui se bécotent sur les
bancs publics bancs publics bancs
publics en ce disant des je t'aime
pathétique ont des petits gueule bien
sympathique
la déambulation reprend avec une
discussion plus politique
l'autoroute 19 mais encore une fois
c'est georges brassens il revient en
tête
c'est drôle
quand on aime ou on n'aime pas mais
quand on comprend donc que philippe
couillard chant club
mais est ce qu'ils d'entre la vie je
chante la vie je danse la vie non j'ai
été déclarée désespérée si mathieu prost
radio canada maintenant qu'on soit
grand-père quand on est con
[Musique]
en plus de coups